pretty big win for the aces tonight
they're just inching that much closer to
possibly WNBA title you can almost sense
this team was going to win the title
here Chris yeah really got game two
tonight and it was tight early on let's
check it out both teams hitting some big
shots it was tied 14-14 when Vegas took
over and never trailed again Ace is
building the double-digit lead in the
second going up 14 39-25 Kelsey Plum
scores 11 in that quarter but Asia
Wilson finishes off the half with a
layup Las Vegas leading 45-37 at the
half now Connecticut cut that lead down
to three points at 49-46
that's when you call on Chelsea Gray to
the rescue she was awesome hitting big
shots terrific shots Las Vegas coasting
to the finish line leading by as many as
20. they go on to win it
85-71 now they're one win away from
their first WNBA title
I mean I don't see any banners
almost any balloons
sure as hell glad I didn't see that
confetti again because we didn't want
nothing yet if you start thinking we
have to win three in a row we have to do
um you know those kind of things it
becomes big so you know we're going to
talk about game three and game three
only
all right and speaking of game three the
aces are off to Connecticut right now
for Thursday's game tip-off set for six
o'clock Las Vegas will be crowned
Champions with just one more win more
reaction coming up in sports Denise